For your final two levels of
competition, generic competition and
budget competition, think larger scale.
Now, generic competition
includes products and
services that fulfill
the same customer needs.
So, a generic competition for
our flavored water here,
would be any other drink that our
potential customer can choose.
So, regular water, sparkling water,
juice, tea, sports drink,
sodas, you get the picture.
Budget competition includes all
products and services that compete for
the same amount of money.
Okay, so wow, let's think about that.
This is a $2.50 water in the Bay Area,
so, everything else that's
$2.50 is our budget competitor.
So, this adorable stuffed monkey,
a sponge, pack of trading cards,
some breakfast cereal, some pencils,
some post-its, a hamburger and fries.
You get the picture.
Now, for more expensive items
in the budget category,
like let's say an engagement ring,
you might be competing for a car, or
a down payment to a house or
part of it or vacation.
You get the picture.
Just think larger scale.